the Joe Rogan experience do you ever
listen to music when you're you're
pondering an equation or whether you're
going over a problem it's an interesting
question when I was in college I
couldn't have any sound on when I was
trying to say learn quantum mechanics or
relativity I would find that it would
capture my brain to fully and then I
couldn't focus on the equations that I
was trying to understand but the funny
thing is in writing this book for the
very first time I found that there were
passages that I couldn't write if it was
quiet I needed to have music playing
because in some sense by focusing too
directly on what I was trying to say I
couldn't say it hmm I only found that I
could make progress in certain kinds of
descriptions by allowing my brain to fly
off through whatever musical experience
I was playing and allowing the freedom
of thought to then emerge within that
unusual for me environment what kind of
music well it varied incredibly a lot of
slayer no but uh so some of it was
classical I remember there's one vital
of passage and I was writing words do
you know pentatonix the they are a
spectacular acapella group who are able
to take songs that you have heard and
transform them into sort of transcendent
performances so you should check these
guys out but other times you know it
would just be loud rock lud beatles loud
Rolling Stones the soundtrack from the
greatest showman
you know just blaring that thing and and
somehow it just allowed me a certain
kind of linguistic freedom that I could
not acquire in my normal way of being in
the world which is everyone's quiet let
me just work out my equations and I need
total focus and no distraction so is
this something that you sort of evolved
over the course of your career
absolutely absolutely was not there
early on and you know there's this
phenomenon I don't know if this is
anything more than a meta
or an analogy but whatever you know
there's certain things in the night sky
that you can't see if you look at them
directly but by looking off axis you're
able to invoke other qualities of the
eye that are able to sense those
features of the night sky and I kind of
feel like it's the same thing
sometimes by focusing directly on what
you want to do you can't do it and
you've got to look Oh bleep you got to
look off axis metaphorically and that's
the only way that you can accomplish
what you set out to do and certainly
music is one of the ways to take one's
attention and shift it in a different
direction to get that oblique view of
what it is that you're trying to do and
I have found that it allows for progress
that otherwise is unattainable and is
that the case also when you were writing
this book it absolutely was a case right
in this book you know there you know I
have a very a wife is very understanding
so we have a house ups and we live in
Manhattan you know I met Columbia but
she would let me go up to our house
upstate with the dogs and by myself and
I would disappear for weeks on end and
I'd hold myself up in this cabin in the
woods and I would sometimes write deep
into the night and there were no
neighbors around so I could turn on the
music at whatever volume I found useful
and I would do it and I would find you
know that it freed up a certain kind of
creative thought process that to me was
striking because I had never approached
work in that way before and it was
really deeply interesting so how did you
come to this idea of doing it that way I
was struggling on certain things and I
felt as though I am approaching this in
a very flat-footed way I want it right
about this you know say what about right
about human creativity or I want to
write about religious engagement and I
am just doing what I've always done
which is I have this equation and I want
to solve it so I'm going to bring the
tools of mathematics to bear to solve it
and I was approaching this writing
project in exactly the same mind frame
and as it wasn't working I said let me
smack my brain around a little bit and
and so one way of you know it could be
psychedelics I didn't go that direction
but I smacked it around by forcing
myself to be subject to a great deal of
distraction in the environment around me
and it really made a difference it's
interesting that you did it in a
calculated manner yes oh sorry I can't
break free Foley from my my my physicist
training you know but it's wise I mean
yeah that that way of doing it is well
and it's also a time-tested you know
from write fry throw to you know yeah in
the front of things you never worked for
me in the past because the focus I think
when I'm doing mathematics it does need
at least for me personally to be that
kind of non distracted total focus on
what's going on as a right writer it's a
very romantic notion to you have to go
to the woods and a cabin that's what's
up right that's what everybody wants to
do Yeah right right exactly you know and
I'm missing is whiskey I supposed to get
drunk out there like I said I hardly
ever drink you know but um it was an
unusual creative experience which to me
opened up a different way of going about
trying to to create things in the world
[Applause]